[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israel
vielleicht seid ja noch auf der suche
nach einem richtig leckeren
weihnachtlichen bisher das hätte bei mir
genau richtig denn ich habe hier ein
triple gemacht dass ich ein sehr
einfaches die sehr weil es einfach in so
eine schöne glasschale geschichte wird
aber ich habe jetzt eine glasschale mit
mit fuß ich finde sie einfach ein
bisschen edel aus aber kann es einmal
ganz toll präsentieren und es fällt eben
nicht auf dass man das eben mal kurz
gezaubert hat ich habe hier drei
schichten also eigentlich sechs
schichten aber die wiederholen sich
unten habe ich nämlich nur richtig tolle
zimt creme darüber ist eine ramona
samantha maritime keksen sage ich euch
gleich was dazu und in der mitte und
auch hier ganz oben habe ich noch
apfelkompott also im prinzip ist ein
bratapfel bisher wirklich total lecker
mit einer richtig tollen karamellsoße
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach wie
sich die einzelnen komponenten
hergestellt habe und startete gleich mit
dem apfelkompott und mit der
karamellsoße fürs apfelkompott brauche
ich eine unbehandelte zitrone einen
sternanis eine zimtstange 50 vom
fallrohr zucker und vier äpfel und für
die karamellsoße brauche ich 100 gramm
zucker drei teelöffel butter 80 gramm
sahne und etwas an den decks tritt ich
hatte zuerst mit dem apfelkompott und
nehme jetzt mal die 44 apple das ist die
sorte pink lady aber ihr könnt auch
etwas säuerliche äpfel nehmen aber mit
grad die da dann werden die geschält und
die schale könnt ihr übrigens verwenden
um zum beispiel einen richtig leckeren
appetit zu machen mache ich uns nämlich
auch gleich findet nämlich immer sehr
schade wenn äpfel geschält werden müssen
[Musik]
die äpfel sind ist entkernt jetzt weil
ich sie würfeln und zwar in fünf
millimeter würfel das könnte jetzt
entweder wir besser machen oder zum
beispiel mit alligator
[Musik]
die äpfel kommen jetzt in den großen
topf und bevor sie jetzt braun werden
gebe ich jetzt noch die zitronenschale
mit dazu und dann eben noch den saft der
zitrone
die vorne sitzt übrigens unser kleiner
weihnachtswichtel plötzlich ein espresso
rausgelassen und ein kleines plätzchen
aber ich habe noch keinen namen für ihn
vielleicht findet ihr einen namen
und dann können wir ihnen schön wenn
eine weil ich finds ein schock für mich
drauf das sieht so süß aus
ursache dieser anstellt
[Musik]
zitrone habe ich jetzt drin jetzt noch
die gewürze zimtstange und anis jetzt
kommt jetzt sogar mit rein
ich nehm ich 200 allroad zucker aber
natürlich könnt ihr auch einen ganz
normalen weißen zucker nehmen aber das
einfach richtig schön aromatisch und
passt wirklich sehr gut zu den äpfeln
jetzt werde ich den topf auf mittlerer
stufe stellen
und lass das ganze dann so etwa zehn
minuten einkochen getrieben habe ich was
auch zu einer apfelschorle gegeben da
mache ich gleich mtv darin gleich die
gewürze mit rein und in diesem topf
werde ich in free caramel soße
zubereiten
das heißt hier kommt jetzt der zucker
rein und wird auf höchster stufe
karamellisiert und ganz wichtig ist bei
der karamellsoße dass die butter und die
sahne raumtemperatur haben
ja
[Musik]
sobald der zucker dann karamellisiert
ist stelle ich den herrn bisschen runter
da habt ihr einfach keine gefahr da
verbrennt und jetzt gebe ich die sahne
mit rein
deswegen sollte sie auch raumtemperatur
haben meine so ein bisschen kalt aber
sich kein problem
verklumpte einfach ganz kurz wird aber
gleich wieder flüssig dann gebe ich auch
gleich die butter mit rein
und etwas vanille extrakt für den
geschmack
gerne auch eine prise salz mit reingeben
jetzt auch kurz
salz hebt noch mal so ein bisschen den
süßen geschmack und gleich die noch aus
und jetzt wenn ich nur noch kurz warten
bis sie trocken hier gelöst sind die
kommentar durch weil eben meine sache
etwas zu kalt und ich war dethloff bis
die app frischen wind und wetter an
beides einfach abkühlen lassen
[Musik]
während des apfelkompott und die
karamellsoße noch abkühlen werde ich
schon mal das granulat herstellen das
habt ihr vielleicht schon gehört und
zwar besteht es aus haferflocken und
müssen zum beispiel und man kann damit
eben sein müsli selber machen und ich
werde jetzt aber flocken verwenden und
zeigt euch mal kurz die zutaten
ich habe jetzt hier 80 gramm honig 230
kerne haferflocken und 200 gramm
américaine kekse kernigen haferflocken
das seht ihr jetzt hier das sind diese
hier diesen zeit hoch so wie man
haferflocken eigentlich immer erkennt
und es ist in zarte haferflocken und die
sind einfach so ein bisschen feiner in
der textur wenn ihr zum beispiel einen
haferbrei markovic dann ist das hier ein
bisschen schleimiger und die hier sind
so ein bisschen bis fester und jetzt
nehmen wir eben die bis festeren wegen
gebe ich jetzt hier schon mal auf mein
bett und nehmen dann honig dazu das
ganze kann man natürlich auch sirup zum
beispiel machen
und dann vermischt ihr das jetzt schön
miteinander geht tatsächlich am
einfachsten mit den händen
[Musik]
ich hab es hier schön flach auf dem
gleich verteilt und an dieser stelle
könnte man jetzt auch gewürze mit
reinbringen zählt zum beispiel ein
eigenes zimmer oder papa opa hat das
schokoladige jedenfalls kommt es jetzt
so in den backofen und wir dann bei 200
grad ober unterhitze solange größte bis
es schön goldbraune dauert etwa 15 bis
20 minuten
wo fehlt jetzt das fertige gramm nun aus
so richtig schön knusprig goldbraun ist
auf jeden fall auch die backzeit achten
und dann wenn es schön duftet dann ist
es im prinzip schon fertig herunter und
kann jetzt schon bald die creme machen
bei der creme habe ich mich jetzt für
mascarpone sahne creme entschieden
dafür brauche ich 400 milliliter sahne
500 gramm mascarpone etwas vanille
extrakt 50 gramm puderzucker und einen
teelöffel zimt
es geht jetzt auch ganz einfach die
mascarpone und die kommt in eine
rührschüssel das könnte jetzt einem
handrührgerät oder auch mit der
küchenmaschine machen
dann verlor ich die mascarpone ein wenig
so wird es einfach schön cremig kann
auch schon mal ran extractor zu geben
und sind puffer den bruder zucker
und auch ganz langsam sie sahen
seht euch die sache rein geht merkt es
ist halb vergessen
da kommt natürlich noch neuen trainer
vor seiner tat gleich mit rein
[Musik]
und dann kann ich die creme zum schreib
schlagen
jetzt kann ich das treffen schon in die
form füllen und damit das ganze richtig
hübsch und sauber aussieht welche die
gremien in einen spritzbeutel füllen
ohne loch chile
das heißt ihr könnt zum beispiel auch
einen gefrierbeutel nehmen so kann man
nämlich am saubersten arbeite ich tag im
sommer von arbeiten und dann passierte
das hirn
[Musik]
mein spritzbeutel schützen bisschen
freude aber das macht jetzt nicht
spritzig hier eine schicht creme hinein
ein bisschen
[Musik]
verteile ich jetzt ganz vorsichtig mit
einem löffel
[Musik]
darüber kommt jetzt die schicht mit den
amara teenie keksen und das ganze
schicht ich zweimal das heißt hier wird
die hälfte der creo mit sich die hälfte
der martini die hälfe des granada und
die hälfte der epfl unternehmen dir
einfach so viel wie eben in eure form
reinpasst und falls jetzt nicht so eine
glasform habt dann nehmt ihr zum
beispiel kleine gläser und könnte es
auch schon den einzelnen stationen
einrichten
selbst rösel ich so ein bisschen
[Musik]
darüber kommt eine schicht karamellsoße
und wenn die karamellsoße zu dickflüssig
ist gibt die einfach noch ein bisschen
sahne dazu und zurück sie erwärmt sich
noch einmal ganz kurz
und da könnte so die konsistenz einfach
selbst bestimmen ob ich zu nämlich auch
gemacht
jetzt die schicht und darüber kommt dann
das ganze einfach noch einmal geschichte
mit der ausnahme dass ich ist am ende
cara mensch ich drüber fließen lassen
[Musik]
das treffen ist durch gekühlt jetzt
werde ich verlieren und zwar am besten
mit dem löffel einmal von oben nach
unten durch
zitat am anfang sehr gut aus danach wird
leider zerstört jetzt ist es liegt
elegant auslösen wenn wir so ein buffet
hat über so was kommt ich hab's doch
schnell gemacht oder zu schnell gemacht
man kann es als super vorbereiten
man denkt einfach ab und stellt in den
kühlschrank und ich werde auch noch eine
zweite variante auf jeden fall machen
ich habe so viele ideen hat mich dann am
ende doch wird apfel und amerika
entschieden hierher spiel da hinten mit
aufstellt haben wie man hört richtig gut
einfach mal alle komponenten
ich habe dieses canola selber gemacht
also die haferflocken okay ich bin jetzt
hoch
ehrlich
also wenn es nicht weihnacht wichtig da
weiß ich nicht der stern ist und auch
komisch mix beschreiben wie ein
perfektes weihnachten wirkung
also ich find's schön in so einem
treffen berater als sowas knackiges
knusprig ist martha viele komponenten
dann machs kräftiges weiches und dann
diese gremien diese cremige masse also
die geringe daheim eine blumenvase ab
dann macht es gelungen war so das ist
eines terriers schale ok auf ihre
richtig genial macht es unbedingt nach
montag das mal zeigen die kamera tom
katzmarek ruhig und es ist so gigantisch
wicken tolles weihnacht ließ es hier
also ein sehr schönes weihnachtliches er
ich werde jetzt noch mal abdeckung in
den kühlschrank geben denn bei uns gibt
es mal was zum essen und danach das
dessert und falls ihr das rezept nach
machen wollt geht auf sase - blog.de das
noch mal für euch und ich wünsche euch
ganz viel spaß beim nachmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal
rainer stets mit ferdinand weg ja und
ich weiß ja warum du diese kernigen
gelungen ist ja genau die kernigen weil
sie einfach viel biss haben
[Musik]